let's talk about this uh the story we
have here from the national review
trump says he intends to sue cnn for
defamation now how much is this just
trump blown smoke or is he really going
to do it it's impossible to sue people
it is it really did you see i don't get
it was it clarence thomas did he say
that there's a potential case coming in
front of the court that will change and
actually loosen the standards by which
you can actually do these sorts of
things i think that would be a very
healthy step in the right direction so
here's what trump said he said i have
notified notified cnn of my intent to
file a lawsuit over their repeated
defamatory statements against me i will
also be commencing actions against other
media outlets who have defamed me and
defrauded the public regarding the
overwhelming evidence of fraud
throughout the 2020 election i will
never stop fighting for the truth and
for the future of our country now
that'll be interesting and i don't think
trump will will get anywhere with with
suing them over fraud stuff first and
foremost i think trump thoroughly
misunderstands a lot of uh the 2020
election stuff i think what we saw with
sydney powell and lynn wood
really exemplifies that trump was given
a lot of bad info
i think he's wrong in that regard he was
but i think he could have focused on a
good friend molly hemingway wrote a book
rigged i think there are definitely
serious questions about 2020 but i think
you were right
i mean sydney when all these and that's
the kraken
right right right right crazy stuff that
threw everything into chaos and i have
to wonder if those people were
intentionally working against trump i
feel like well because i'll tell you you
know i i i want to talk about the
lawsuits of the media so i don't want to
get in but i will mention you know
pennsylvania changing the rules on
voting was ruled unconstitutional after
the fact but did you see what
wisconsin's state supreme court just
said recently they said that the
uh unsecured ballot drop boxes were
illegal oh right right right you might
have called in the question
there's a lot of stuff that's weird this
is this is the problem with trump and
the fraud narrative is that it's
procedural it's procedural questions on
policy and law that need to be rectified
and don't if that keeps becoming the
narrative because
it it's it's it's universal mail-in
voting rules the question the question
of the constitutionality of universal
mail and voting right election month
versus election day
unmanned drop boxes so
i don't want to get into it yeah we
don't want to go down that i want to
talk about this media lying about
january 6 and all of that stuff
certainly trump has his opinion on all
those things
i got to say though
if he's suing on those grounds dismissed
instantly yeah because for one the
courts are going to be entirely biased
against hearing any of this stuff but if
he's talking about january 6 then i
think he might actually yeah he might
actually win like what we're seeing now
with the media saying i'm not saying win
in every single instance i know lauren
gave a look of doubt i don't think
people win especially when you're a
public figure like trump even starting
these defamation lawsuits i mean he'd
have the money to do it i guess we'd be
able to start but it's so difficult to
win a defamation lawsuit especially when
you're
when you have other media writing the
same thing about you any media company
will use that as an offense they'll say
everyone else is writing the same thing
so we just wrote it maybe it's not even
about that i mean maybe it's just about
bringing this to the forefront again to
have a conversation about all of these
things
here's what'll happen one news outlet
let's call it news outlet a will write
something false about lauren
news outlet b will pick it up right news
outlet c will pick it up news outlet a
will retract and apologize and now you
have two outs citing each other and if
you sue one of those they'll say it's
reported as fact by news outlet c you
sue then they'll say it's reported as
fact by news outlet b
and then even if it is wrong they'll say
all we are doing is conveying what
another newshour already said which we
believe to be true there's no malice and
we're allowed to say it and no one ever
sees the correction it's always
published on a different page months
later and but it still counts it's still
good enough you don't have to that's
what's crazy to me is there's like no
legal recourse for if an article about
you goes completely viral there's no
expectation that the apology afterwards
that will prevent any sort of legal you
know financial scooping will be as viral
and there's no yeah no expectation one
person could see the correction and
that's still okay we're not legally
culpable now that's nuts nuts
there's pros and cons cons um the idea
is that it's it's difficult to sue
anyone in the public space but the
problem then is
they just the media the corporate press
lies about basically everything so i was
thinking about this earlier in order to
sue you need standing and injury which
is insane
how do you prove injury are you going to
go find the guy who wrote you the donor
check who canceled it and then have him
testify that he was going he i wrote the
donor check and as soon as i saw that
defamation i tore it up so proving that
is insane i think we should be allowed
to sue
for correction
that's it
for correction so you go to a court you
say i can definitively prove the spirit
of what they're saying their statements
are untrue
and then maybe they got to pay legal
fees if they lose for publishing
something false and that's fair
and then it's like then they gotta issue
up an apology a statement they gotta
publish on the front page and leave it
up there for like a week or something
for everyone to see
it's remarkable to me
that you can have a major press a major
news organization lie
and so i've been through this i've
talked to lawyers and they're like what
are your damages and then i was like
well obviously they're trying to get me
banned shadow band reduce wages and
things like that or income and they're
like can you prove it it's like unless
unless we file a subpoena in discovery
against youtube to ask them if they're
and they and youtube does this
in response to smears youtube has
de-ranked and shadow banned many people
hurting their businesses how do you
prove that to a court at the very least
i should be able to sue and say your
honor i can prove what they said is
false
i would like them to be ordered to issue
a correction that's it there you go do
you think that in the correction they
should state that they were also sued to
make a correction so it sets it apart
from ones that they just chose to do yes
it should say a court upon finding of
our defamation has instructed us to
correct the record and make sure our
audience understands
we were wrong
on this count and this count and this
count we apologize for the error they're
going to be on their front page for a
week that could incentivize them to do
it before they get sued so they don't
have to make the say like hey we got
sued also well so this is actually what
happens
organizations will defame you and then
when you move to file a suit they'll
retract in a very weak and pathetic way
to remove standing and then when you go
to a judge they'll say they've already
removed the article okay case dismissed
and then i'm like now i've lost donors
now people won't work here because the
media has threatened because that's like
pulling the bullet out of someone's arm
and being like all right there's no
bullet so there's no proof that i take a
good example exactly yup now the wound's
still there we need reform on defamation
because i'll tell you this if i made a
mistake if i if if timcast.com published
something incorrect
and someone came to me and said that's
wrong i'd say sorry about that we'll fix
it immediately
and there you go yeah because you're
committed to actually
to the truth so there's no net negative
for those who are committed to the truth
if we have a system in which you can sue
someone to force a correction no i think
this is a bigger question i'd love to
hear your thoughts on this i mean
obviously one of the
aspects of our society in our republic
is a free and fair press
that's meant to actually pursue the
truth to provide transparency that can
then lead to accountability so the
american people understand what's going
on there's
accountability this is the one thing
where we clearly do not have a free and
honest press we have corporate
propagandists what are the steps that
are needed to actually get
them to the point grudgingly or
otherwise where they're actually focused
on trying to be at least objective on
some levels i don't know that's when
clarence
went on the market yeah i mean part of
it is winning the market at the same
time there have to be consequences for
it yeah because there are no
consequences right now they can get away
with
anything they can say anything they want
and that they can call january 6 people
seditious insurrectionists and there are
no consequences for that when they had
nothing to do with any of that at all
well there are people on january 6 who
have been charged that but they're
innocent until proven guilty but a lot
of these people had doors open for them
by police i've seen videos yeah they
they walked right past the police
department
yeah they waved them and opened the door
yeah one guy got acquitted because of it
and aoc
herself her videos yeah on the on the
steps of the capitals no i i if if we
can't get back to the point we i totally
agree with the competition control the
market or get more of a market share
i just kind of we've got to figure out
how there are consequences it should not
be for profit there should be pain
absolutely absolute pain for what some
of the stuff that they're doing right
like i mean
they lied about trump every step of the
way yeah almost every single thing ever
the shinzo abe thing i remember that one
when he was feeding the fish and they
they cropped the video so you could only
see trump dumping the food in and what
they crapped out was that shinzo abe did
it first he poured the food in and
looked at trump and then trump said okay
and threw his food in but they tried to
make it seem like trump did something
wrong to insult him it's insane could
you say like any kind of news
organization that would qualify under
protections as a news organization it
has to be a 501c3 no no no
for profit the for-profit news is crazy
because they just make it up
right it's a problem that's right
so so i'll tell you guys it's really
simple
cnn what's what should they do should
they spend a hundred thousand dollars
salary to investigate a story or do they
lie
what what makes more money for these
corporations you put out a lie right you
get a million bucks from this viral
story the next day you issue a
retraction here's the best part the
retraction makes money too now the
retraction let's say
someone news news not just cnn any news
outlet writes an article that goes viral
claiming something insane
they get all the ad revenue from it when
they issue their retraction a small
percentage of people will read the
retraction which also has ads on it
so they'll even make money retracting
they don't give back the ad dollars when
they retract the story they keep them
i i think you should be able to sue and
you should get all revenue generated
from the from the false peace oh that's
a good one i love it um i also think
just like mocking these outlets into
oblivion completely
it's like a scary thing to say we have
to destroy faith in like the
journalistic institutions but we do we
need people to just not trust them at
all which means what they'll do is when
they go to sites to read they'll have to
actually read the article they'll have
to see if there's sources and then they
can regain trust in a website they'll be
like okay this site that i've been
reading for a while actually sources
things i'm going to start reading them
there cannot be an immediate assumption
that because it's a journalistic outlet
it's going to be correct it has to be
the opposite it's it's it's it's an
issue of human behavior though yeah i
mean people don't read articles they
read headlines but i was also going to
say uh
like are people really looking for the
truth are they looking for something
that will reinforce their
presuppositions for comfort i mean we're
just talking about you know for the four
thousandths whatever time are they going
to get trump it's reinforcing their
biases they just want to hear what they
already believe right so i don't know i
think that's an interesting question
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you